the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu alright everyone welcome
back today we're going to talk about the
profiling tools available on cell to
help you evaluate how your programs are
running and next hour I'll talk about
simdi which is how you can take
advantage of the hardware support for
data parallelization first up I'd like
to follow up with some questions that we
had it last time about gdb and then I'll
discuss some of the various methods for
profiling on cell I'll talk about the
cell simulator and using the decrement
errs and then we're going to talk about
static profiling and instruction
reordering which I started to get into
last time so first up we ran into some
problems last time with gdb various
error messages first thing sometimes gdb
is going to examine the wrong variable
as we saw when the names are ambiguous
one thing you can do to get around this
we had problems with ambiguity between
variables which had the same name where
one of them was in the SPU thread and
one of them was in the PPU thread and so
to work around this one thing you can do
is use SPU gdb which we'll just lock on
to a particular SPU thread then you can
just look for then you can just look for
variable names in that thread you can
also of course rename your variables
second problem is that sometimes gdb
will delete your breakpoints before you
want it to delete them reason being it
will remove breakpoints when whenever
the program associated with a break
point has been unloaded but sometimes
you have more than one thread running on
more than one thread running the same
program and so the second one you won't
be able to break into so again you can
use SP gdb to lock onto a particular
thread if you want to if you want to do
that another thing you can
you is kind of for example put a delay
loop at the end of your spu thread in
order to keep the thread running for as
long as possible it seems that as long
as gdb doesn't unload that thread then
it won't delete your break point and
finally some of I saw this kind of
cryptic error thread event breakpoint
gdb should not stop yeah Indian one
thing to get around this it seems that
this problem doesn't happen on spu gdb
so I'll just recap how to use spu gdb to
be to debug your programs last time we
were using mostly ppu gdb which will
help you debug kind of both your ppu
program and your SPU program together
and you're able to switch between all
the threads that are available on the
other hand when you're using spu gdb
it's just going to lock on to a
particular SPU thread so what you do is
you invoke your original ppu program
with SP you debug star equals one and
then you can background it now what
happens is every time that you're every
time that your SP you sorry or every
time that you're a program spawns a new
SP you thread it will print the process
ID and then actually that thread the
spawn thread will stop and wait for a
debugger to attach to it so at this
point you can run spu gdb Dash P and
then the process number that they give
you and when you attach to it you can
continue that thread to resume debugging
all right any questions
okay so the cell simulator excuse me the
cell simulator is one of the tools that
we have available to help you debug this
is how you invoke it if you have it
installed opt IBM system sim cell bin
systems in and you want to use dash G to
use the graphical interface and a little
window will pop up and you'll click go
the window looks like this it actually
from here you can have a lot of
fine-grained control over how your
program is running in fact you can
advance your you can advance the state
of the simulation cycle by cycle to look
at what's going on inside the simulated
cell system and when you boot up this
simulator you can actually get a
complete Linux environment in there with
the next term and what you can do in
this Linux environment is you can copy
over programs and then you can you can
copy over programs which were compiled
for the cell and then you can run them
in order to transfer a program to your
simulated system so that you can run it
you can use this you can use this
function or you can use this program
call through which is available on the
simulated system and what it will do is
it will grab on to a file which is on
the host system and copy it in and it'll
just it will just put it on standard out
so you can redirect it to whatever file
you want and then when you make it
executable then you can run it all right
questions while you're in the simulator
you can you can view a lot of different
things well you can get a lot of
information about the state of the
machine in particular you can you know
look at the registers at any particular
time again with you know clock step bike
lock step this might not be as
interesting now that you have the
debugger and you can run the debugger on
real hardware but one thing which this
which the cell simulator does get you is
these dynamic profiling tools and what
it will do is it will look at the state
of the simulation and we'll figure out
you know where things are stalling and
where the time is being spent by the
processor and you can get separate stats
like these
let's see it tells you for example total
cycle count stalls for various reasons
you can get all these statistics
separately for the PPU and each SPU so
this can be very helpful if you're
trying to do for example you know you're
trying to figure out exactly what's
going on on each SPU do load balancing
whatever all right and so that's and so
these statistics will hold these
statistics will cover you know whatever
length of the program you run but you
can also get more fine-grained
statistics using these profiling
functions so if you include profile H in
your program then you get access to
these functions profile clears start and
stop and what these will do is there
actually when they get compiled into
your program there are no ops when you
run them on a real cell processor but
the simulator will be able to latch on
to them and you can use those to start
and stop regions of interests for
profiling all right now the simulator
comes with the SDK and it's a little bit
cumbersome to install so we haven't we
haven't made it available yet on the
actual ps3 hardware you can run it on
x86 and so if your group would like to
get set up with that on on one of your
computers or we'll try and make it
available on our hardware if there's
enough interest so please let us know
all right ok the next thing we'll cover
is using decrement errs to profile your
program this is one way of one way you
can use dynamic profiling which actually
doesn't require the simulator so when
you when you get information from the
decrement ores you can run these
programs on on your actual cell hardware
basically the decrement ER is just a
counter that counts down at a constant
rate so you can use it as a clock to
figure out how long different events are
lasting and the the rate at which the
decrement er counts down is not that
fast so you're not going to be able to
use it to tie
things on the order of you know a few
clock cycles it's best for its best for
timing things which are maybe you know
on the order of thousands of
instructions in length and how you use
it is there are these SPU right channel
and SP you read channel functions which
give you access to some of the internals
of the Cell processor and and so here's
an example set up you can use basically
first you call right channel and you
pass in the this you know mfc decrement
or event thing and what that will do is
kind of initialize this decrement or
counter for you and and then you read
the value before and after the function
you want a profile and when you subtract
that just gives you that just gives you
the length or the time that was elapsed
in some arbitrary units and of course
it's counting down so you want to
subtract the start from the end and
after you're done using it you can you
can do another right channel to kind of
stop the counter from continuing all
right any questions
okay let's let's continue talking about
instruction reordering which I started
last time so I'm going to kind of start
from the beginning this time and maybe
it'll be more coherent so on the cell
architecture when you're looking at you
know what instructions are being run the
instructions are mostly going to be of
the form you know evaluate some function
of some of the registers and write the
result to some other register and the
assembly file are what you get when you
run with GCC chess is just going to be
you know a human readable representation
of these instructions and I'll show you
how to read that actually later and you
can think of these instructions just as
you know executing in series just in the
order in which they appear in the
assembly so if you think of you know one
instruction starting and then finishing
the next instruction comes in finishes
that should be you know consistent with
the actual behavior of the hardware now
for real hard we're waiting for one
instruction to finish before the next
one starts is going to be too slow so
there are these various optimizations we
pull or that they do on the hardware in
order to run instructions sooner than
when the previous instruction finishes
so the big one of these is pipelining
where you have multiple stages inside
your processor and you can run each
instruction you can push each
instruction in before the previous one
has completed and and pipelining you're
going to be subject to these
dependencies between instructions for
example if one instruction reads from a
value that the previous previous
instruction wrote then clearly you can't
start the second instruction until after
the first instruction has completed the
Cell processor also has actually has
multiple pipelines in which you can
insert instructions and another
optimization that they do is a branch
prediction in order to in order to
reduce stalls from from branching now
but yes so static branch prediction
means or rather the way it's done on the
cell is that what's predicted for the
branch is not going to be affected by
the by the history of which branches
have been taken which and some other
processors actually do use this
information all right now now the thing
about pipelining is that because we
still have to honor these dependencies
between instructions the order in which
we evaluate instructions that's going to
make a difference on how long the
program runs so let's take the simple
example where we have three instructions
a B and C and we have this pipeline
processor where we can insert
instructions at these clock ticks so
suppose that see depends on B and there
are no other depends dependencies in the
system then this then this sequence of
instructions is going to take five
cycles because we can push be in after
the first cycle but we can't push see
and until two cycles after that is that
clear questions all right now because
see depends on be it kind of makes sense
to push be as far up as we can in order
to kind of ease this dependency so if we
execute be before a instead of after a
and remember we can reorder be and a
however we want because there's no
dependencies between them then we can
start be at the first tick then we put
in a right after that and then C and now
the sequence only takes four clock
cycles all right so observe that when we
put in see in this third clock cycle we
actually couldn't have put in the third
instruction any sooner because no matter
what the dependencies were and so in
general we're going to want that to be
the case where we want instructions to
be waiting on the pipeline rather than
on dependencies so that means in the
first picture there's this there's this
stall of one clock cycle and we're going
to want to eliminate these kind
stalls all right so what we're going to
do is we're going to use these static
profiling tools to figure out where
stalls happen now the first thing we're
going to do the first thing that we have
to do is generate the assembly and the
instruction schedule that goes with it
and so you can use GCC big s and the
same flag works with xlc to generate the
assembly and then we have this utility
that we have this utility called SPU
timing which runs on the cell and which
will tell you the instruction schedule
basically it'll take in your assembly
file and tell you exactly when each
instruction in that assembly gets
scheduled if you call it with dash
running count then it will tell you the
running count of clock cycles at each
stage which means if you look at the
last number that will tell you at how
long your program took to run in clock
cycles and we'll write the output to a
file of the same name as the input but
with dot timing at the end now if you're
using our make file you can actually do
all this the generate the assembly and
the timing info all in one step by doing
SPU timing equals one and then make the
name of the dot s file all right now if
you'll recall on cell we're going to
have only in order execution the the
instructions are just going to execute
in the order that they're specified in
the assembly in the assembly and and the
set because the cell has dual pipelines
that means there's two pipelines in
which instructions can go and in the
pipelines are going to be selected just
based on the instruction type and of
course two instructions are only going
to go in simultaneously when the
dependencies allow it
right so if you're looking at the
assembly you're going to see lots of
lines of this form op destination and
then the source registers so when you're
trying to figure out dependencies it's
going to be helpful to be able to look
at each line of the assembly and figure
out what registers that line is reading
from and what registers that line is
writing to and there's also information
in the assembly file I went into that
last time which tells you kind of for
each chunk of assembly what the
corresponding source what the
corresponding source file line is
alright and the the actual output of the
static profile or like I said it will
spit out a schedule of when each
instruction runs and and in this
schedule you're going to see one digit
for each cycle that the instruction is
running so however many digits so there
are that's how many cycles are being
used and in front of in front of some of
the instructions you're going to see
these dashes which represents stalls so
these three dashes in front of this
instruction FM means that means that
based on the pipeline you could have
scheduled this instruction up here right
after the previous previous instruction
finished however because you're waiting
on particular dependencies you're only
going to be able to schedule it these
three cycles later so that's a three
cycle stall and this static profiler
output is also going to show other
information the original assembly
appears on the right hand side and which
pipeline the instructions are going into
is going to show up on the left any
questions about this format
dolus you just means that these
instructions are going to be executed at
the same time people figure out for
example is the latency for FM in certain
circles the second
ok
pardon
uh over here all right so these are the
arguments to the assembly instructions
so remember the first one is going to be
the destination register and the other
ones are going to be all the source
registers that that instruction is going
to use all right so again we want to be
able to reorder these instructions to
minimize stalls and what you're going to
do is you're going to try and look for
instructions that are going to take a
long time potentially for example loads
and floating point instructions are
going to take a long time and and if
these instructions have dependencies
then those dependencies are going to
stall so not only do you want to
minimize stalls you want to you also
want to duel issue instructions whenever
possible although that's a little bit
more difficult to just kind of eyeball
but anyway if you get up to an ideal the
ideal running point where you're able to
duel issue every instruction then that
means you're going to be running two
instructions per cycle or it's going to
take one half cycle per instruction
anyway going through these assembly
files and you know figuring out where
the dependencies are which instructions
you can move around it's kind of tedious
and you're not going to be able to apply
these techniques to your entire program
so if you only have you know limited
time what you're going to have to do is
try these on you know the most critical
code first and that's usually going to
be loop bodies because those are going
to get executed many many times and any
savings that you see there will be
multiplied many many times over so I'm
going to go through an example of one
possible optimization you could do so so
we'll actually go through these these
same files in in the exercise about two
minutes from now this is from lab one
and this is one of the this is one of
the code snippets or the assembly
snippets from the SPU program so notice
that over here we have these load
instructions
followed by a I guess this is a shift
instruction and and there's a to kind of
pairs of these and in each one the shift
instruction is going to depend on the
result of the previous load does
everyone see that from the arguments so
so now the problem is that because this
shift is happening right after the load
it's going to stall for a long time
because the load takes six cycles all
right so what can we do over here in
order to reduce stalling yep yeah we can
do the loads concurrently and in general
we just want to move these loads up as
high as we can so if I move if I move
these the two loads up to the top of
this oops the top of this snippet then
we have two loads followed by all the
instructions that came after now the
first shift is going to stall by only
two cycles and the second shift is not
going to stall at all all right so
pardon so the question is what would
this change look like in code the thing
is that kind of the order of these
generate instructions is going to be
dependent on the compiler and it's
really up to the compiler how it wants
to order these instructions so this
change is not going to be reflected in
like your C code and that's why you have
to do these optimizations after the
assembly is generated does that make
sense
if you have a smart compiler then it
might do some some kind of instruction
scheduling in order to minimize stalls
using kind of this methodology yep
program under GCC or SP you with the up
with optimization level three and under
XL city xlc one grand one that one ran
in half the time so it's doing a much
better job of instruction scheduling
than GCC and GCC so that's okay
something if you're if you've got your
choice and the use of you can pilot
working for you yeah yeah my baby views
in general this kind of sort of
low-level assembly hacking for
instructional ordering it's not
something you'll do just because
compilers are getting incredibly good at
doing instruction scheduling but here
the exercises for you to sort of get
familiar with the tools and understand a
little bit more in detail as to what's
going on at the instruction level in the
cell pipelines another thing to note
here is well two things you can consider
here how high up can you push the limits
and why was the first and related I've
is why can't you completely hide the
latency for the first load and hence the
first ship still takes two cycles to
stall so that's dependent on how much
slack do you have a new schedule
dependent on dependencies and where the
loop starts so in some cases you simply
can't hide entire latency in its part of
considerations if you
consider but your Ristic sand the
compilers are getting really good at it
and in case you're wondering I think
this code was compiled using Excel see
on no optimizations which is why there's
you know this really easy opportunity
for optimization here and it turns out
if we run the the timing utility again
we saved eight cycles so notice that on
the previous picture we're going up to
seven in that column and now we're only
going up to the previous nine all right
so what we're going to do for the
exercise right now is you're going to
you can try something like this we're
going to try and do is just improve
performance by rescheduling instructions
and so if you if you download the
tarball you'll get the exact same file I
was working on before and we're going to
have you do is just generate the
assembly practice generating the
assembly modifying it and then
continuing with the rest of the build
process to get a new object file that's
based on your modified assembly all
right any questions now you just need to
you just need to find you know for
example one opportunity for optimization
and you can do the exact same thing that
I did if you want and so the key is just
after you've done your Rio during you
want to rerun the timing utility to see
how many cycles you saved also you want
to of course continue the build process
to get the final executable file and you
want to run that just make sure that
your code is still correct
ah
working up
yeah great thanks
alright
okay so this this static profiling
process does have its limitations the
first is that and this is a pretty major
limitation the the static profiler
assumes that none of the branches are
taken so basically just zips zips
through the entire assembly file in a
straight line so that means you're going
to have a skewed view of how long how
long code inside conditionals or loop
bodies is going to take because
conditionals if their savings in there
they may not they may not run at all and
loop bodies any savings in there make
them make it multiplied many many times
so if for example you see that you've
saved eight cycles in aesthetic schedule
you're going to need to know kind of
some more context that is you know
whether it's inside a loop body and how
many times you expect that to run so
you're going to need a little more
information to get a good idea of how
these instruction reordering are
actually affecting the runtime of your
program and also because this is static
profile which means you're not using an
actual program run to get data you're
not going to get kind of behavior you're
not going to capture any behavior that
depends on the inputs to your program so
for example you don't get any you don't
get counts of how many times each loop
runs or you know when each branch is
taken one other thing to worry about
which isn't going to be manifested in
the in these static British static
static profiling predictions is a branch
prediction now remember the static
profiler is just going to ignore all
branches and the thing is that branch
prediction because a branch prediction
is used to reduce the stall after a
branch is taken by kind of pre fetching
instructions and possibly doing other
things so what we'll do is guess the
direction that the branch will take and
then it will start pre fetching
instructions from the expected place
where it's it's going to resume after
the branch and the thing is if your
branch prediction is wrong then you're
going to incur a pretty large penalty
and the penalty is on the order of 20
cycles while it's all it flushes the
pipeline and starts fetching
instructions from the new place on the
other hand if branch prediction is
is correct then there's no penalty at
all actually so the next instruction
will just resume you know right after
right after the branch anyway anyway you
can give hints to the compiler to tell
it what you think the outcomes of
branches will be and this can this can
help in some circumstances basically
there are these there are these macros
that you can define and what you're
going to use is this built-in expect
compiler intrinsic and what that means
is if you put that inside and if it will
mean you know run the if as if the
condition were exp but then I'm going to
expect that the value of this condition
is going to be for example true or false
all right does that make sense anyway
just one note about the exercise that
you did I believe the original the
original runtime was 469 clock cycles
actually if you werent run xlc with 05
optimizations it will reduce that to a
hundred and eighty-eight so almost two
hundred and eighty cycles of savings all
right so will pardon oh no so the
original code was the original assembly
was compiled on 0 0 or no optimizations
but then you know if you're if you're
doing an optimization by hand that saves
eight cycles off of 0 0 these are
actually pretty easy to find and the 05
optimization level will actually shave
off you know 280 cycles so we'll break
for about 10 minutes and then after the
break we'll do simdi on cell all right